so hi I'm John David Dalton I was
formerly the Pro Performance Program
Manager at chakra i'm also a javascript
library author i developed lodash right
now i am in the developer sorry the web
frameworks ecosystem team on your ms
edge so you'll be seeing me do a lot
more open source work doing poor
requests on your various projects and
things like that but today's talk is on
built-ins written in JavaScript so let's
get into it so I entitled the talk
drawing hands because it's JavaScript
built-ins written in the language itself
under the hood so you can't observe that
it's written in JavaScript but it
actually is and so this allows you to
power and so that's this drawing here
was the lithograph graph was done by MC
Escher and self-hosting I'll be saying
this a lot this is when parts or whole
of a language written in the language
itself but what is this ray this says
bang go on this baby wipes did you leave
this here from your first talk what yeah
krill says hey by the way yeah all right
now that that's done that was my most
important bit all right all right so
yeah yeah you must be here for this all
right so first I'm going to go into the
good the bad and the ugly of built-ins
written in JavaScript so first let's
talk about the good things so ease of
development because they are built ins
and they're written in javascript in
these these engines are open source you
can view them you can see them you can
examine their code we're going to look
at their code in just a little bit and
kind of see how they're made so it
allows you to contribute back to the
project see more contributions naturally
performance the good thing is is is it's
widely used to allow the built-ins to
leverage the same optimizations that
your normal JavaScript gets celeb
from the jit so you get in lining for
free you don't have to do any extra
extra work there and so there gives you
some superior performance so some
engines like Firefox and Chrome I'm
sorry browsers like Firefox and Chrome
will will use JavaScript to implement
array for each filter map every in all
of those because they get the inlining
benefits so experimental API so this is
something i'll be digging into a little
bit later in my job to is is anytime
there is an experimental API like a
proposed api from the w3c you can use
javascript to implement that quickly and
get that into an experimental build and
testable and so debs can try it out and
use it so examples what do I mean when I
say examples are JavaScript methods
built-in in the language let's see do I
have any examples here no i don't but i
can go over here and I've got them so
here's an example of a built-in written
for Mozilla spider monkey and this is
I'll zoom in here and zoom around so you
all can see a little bit better here we
go so here's array index up array index
up is pretty straightforward it's
basically you give it so you have an
array and you're looking for a needle in
a haystack you're looking for the index
of a given element and it does strict
equality comparisons and so this if
you're if you're familiar with shims
this looks really close to a shim right
you can see down here it's doing a
little extra check though it says hey if
this array is packed so there's a
there's a concept in arrays and the
older es5 yes three methods had to be
aware of this is sparse arrays sparse
arrays are these things that I don't
deal with I treat them as all dense but
they have performance impacts and so
that's why this JavaScript function is
forking its behavior based on that so
this is calling into a helper that is I
believe C++ code that allows them to
to Detective if an array is packed or
not so basically dense or sparse and
then it goes here so now we've seen that
that looks pretty straight forward let's
look at let's see we don't need to see
the the is pack this is the check right
here to see if a value is packed and I'm
not a C++ dev so I really don't know a
ton of what's going on there but you can
see that you can you can a mix
javascript and and native methods
together to create your built-in
implementation and that's really cool
here is the eights version of index of
so we can zoom in here you can see it's
doing the same kind of juggling it's
doing a length checks it's doing the
same use like the use sparse variant
check and there it's having to make an
inference about the array so it's having
to guess if the array is likely to be
sparse and then go down this path else
go down another path so you notice that
here they may not have as much insight
into the engine or into the into what's
going on with the values that's being
passed because it's just JavaScript
right so that may be an issue with
implementing it in JavaScript now you
can see here the low dash implementation
of this method and what i'm doing here
is detecting if a value i do a little
bit of argument juggling here i detect
if you're passing true to be able to do
a binary search or if you're passing
just a note and index to do something
like a from index and from there i also
match i throw more functionality into
this and i'll get into this a little bit
with with features but with javascript
implementations of your built-ins and if
you're leveraging javascript i've found
a way in lodash to have better than
built in performance implementing a
simpler subset of the built-in
functionality but what I'm able to do on
top of that then is go back and add
features and still be on par or better
than bill
so in this case I'm also doing a check
for na n so normally index sub doesn't
support in again if you if you try to
look for na n it's always going to
return negative one but in this case
I've added support for that because es6
is starting to be able to match in a in
value so like if you have a set or a map
so i wanted that to be consistent
throughout so you can see here a real
basic implementation did you see the the
the previous implementations were very
complex they had all those forking for
different cases and conditions but you
can see here the vanilla JavaScript
version is basically a for loop doing
the strict equality check and you notice
that if it's na n I hand off to another
helper function because that's not the
common case so these kinds of principles
can also be applied to your array
built-ins in the browser so we'll look
at that the next example I want to show
and discuss is int'l so the
internationalization API and that's this
spec hear that i'll zoom in on because
everyone likes reading technical
specifications huh talks about the Intel
object so in an IE and in ms edge we
implement the Intel internationalization
API in JavaScript and so there's pros
and cons to that so we got in on the
self-hosting game as well so let's go
back to here alright so the good here
the good was we were able to write it in
JavaScript it was able to simplify the
arguments handling of the arguments it
was able to be understood in red so like
I'm not a C++ dev but I know JavaScript
so I can look at that and help out and
say like hey this or that other people
JavaScript dad's that we have could
could do that at the company so it was
it was it was good simplified reading
and understanding integrating with C++
with simpler than we thought about that
allowed us to spin this up rapidly and
get the get that implemented but with
the good comes the bad all of that
JavaScript you know you can coerce
values you've got value of you've got
prototypical inheritance
all these ways that you can manipulate
the language to cause side effects and
your built-ins shouldn't have side
effects right they should just be
isolated you shouldn't be able to to
mess with the surrounding language and
affect their behavior so all of that had
to be had to be guarded against and so
that was tricky to do you have to create
and hold references 22 normally
functions you take for granted and you
have to find ways to guard against
people changing things on the object a
prototype or other other methods that
would cause your functionality to have
side effects there's also heavier
boilerplate because of all of that
spinning up the development of that that
single implementation took longer of
well took more boilerplate to get that
that ready now hopefully future
implementations will already have that
boilerplate in place and then the ugly
so I already mentioned preventing
tainting of internal JS objects but then
you have to be able to test that and try
to to ensure that you're guarding
against that so it not only complicates
the guards so the implementing all the
guards around it but also the testing of
those two and then also ensuring that
you have the correct stack behavior so
if you're debugging and you want to walk
the stack you don't want to go into the
internals of the built-in you want that
to be obscured and hidden away I
remember there was versions of v8 that
had their built-ins written in
JavaScript and you could to string them
and view their source and I was trying
to find the version of that because I
always thought that was so cool but
apparently it leaked things that aren't
supposed to be leaked but awesome and
this would be another one to you don't
want to walk your stack and then via gig
into the internals of the built-in so
there's that the bad and the ugly now
moving on to other things before I said
hey it's great for performance you get
in lining but you also and i ended up
this earlier you also don't have all of
the tools in optimizations and and data
available that the the the the engine
would behind the scenes
so that's why the v8 implementation was
having to make a guess if something was
a sparser rang right they didn't know
right out the gate that something was
and so that can cause overhead and so
i'll show you this going back in 2012 i
had a conference talk and it was called
the hidden costs of JavaScript natives
and that's where I went through and
showed every built-in and how they were
horribly slow compared to vanilla
JavaScript alternatives so that was in
2012 and one of those links was or let's
see index of and I showed the
performance of native versus the vanilla
so let me go to let's see this one and
let's see where we're at
live live demo oh yeah and we're moving
on from this the the benchmark would
show that we're still behind so even
with implementing these methods in
JavaScript they're still not as fast as
simplified alternatives so performance
isn't guaranteed hmm oh sorry that well
this this slide here isn't really
important I'll go back to the other one
so no silver bullet on performance but
I've noticed that in those cases where
you come out of the gate without the the
performance here's one object at a sign
I was very psyched as a library author
to use this method and as soon as it
appeared in windows 10 I tried it out
yay we were sixty percent faster than
vanilla JavaScript alternatives so I was
going to use it in lodash but then I
looked at the other browsers and Firefox
nightly hey they removed their try-catch
logic and object out a sign is on par
with javascript alternatives okay so
it's on par or better that's great but
v8 its sixty-two percent slower than
JavaScript alternatives so it puts me in
a tricky spot of having to make tough
choices about whether I want to go
through all the hoops to fork my code to
use this built-in when it's not as
performance especially in a scenario
that's like a node specific scenario so
the lesson there is that these methods
are all written in JavaScript and their
self hosted except for chakras and
chakras was the one that was the fastest
so in that case we took the lump for
implementation ease of implementation
yes it was harder to implement right
then let's say writing JavaScript
the end result was a faster method out
of the box and we still have room to
optimize like this was normally when you
when you create these methods its
implement first get all your unit tests
passing push it out and then go back in
optimize right so this is this is our
this is our right out of the gate
performance and so if we want we can go
back and iterate over that and improve
that right now we're already giving
developers what they want which is an
API that's fast enough but they don't
have to sit there and pull in another
library dependency which brings me to
developers shouldn't be forced to use a
library to have faster built-in
equivalents I shouldn't have to write
lodash to have faster built-in
performance for these common utility
libraries so I've been pushing at chakra
to to optimize our built-ins and so
that's what that's what we've done we
came out with the blog post where we
talked about specifically array index of
that wasn't a random method picked they
crawled the top sites found the most
used JavaScript methods and then put
them on a priority list for optimization
and array index of was that was one of
the highest es five methods used so i
would say expect more of that i want to
to challenge the other browsers to to
get involved in this and optimize your
built-ins because we're creating a
situation where we spend so much time
creating these methods specifying these
methods testing these methods
implementing these methods in the
browser and then having such poor
performance that developers aren't using
them so who are we making right we
should we should be delighting
developers with things like optimizing
the built-ins and optimizing the usage
pass those paths from es5 to es6 so for
example your spread operator should be
fast and the alternative that should
also be optimized so you're not getting
a penalty for switching to a new syntax
they should make sure that the up the
the paths the fast pads from one
translate to the other so that's what
you'll start seeing a focus on is is
more built in performance
I'm going to hit the next slide and I
don't know what it's going to take me so
here we go all right whoo optimizing the
built-ins which I've already talked
about nice one more all right that's the
end one so I knew it was close if you
want to talk to me in the hallway I'll
talk to you about the other issues and
in tweaks with with this other work
we're doing with optimizing our
built-ins and that's it cool thank you
d